Over the last six months my team and I been all over the country
Checking out your best restaurant nominations
and tonight my search continues with another of the UK's favorite cuisines, Thai
Over the last 10 years Thai food has taken Britain by storm
Even the pub's are doing it now, but really top-notch authentic Thai restaurants are so hard to find actually chance, please
Thank you
I've eaten some great restaurants in Thailand, and I know that secret to authentic Thai food
It's all about getting that balance right between the sweet bitter
Hot sour salty flavors tonight's contenders and have to be at the top of the game to impress me from hundreds of tiny nominations
I've hand-picked my top two to go head-to-head for a place in the semi-finals
From son Andrews Scotland's Gulf and capital, it's Nam Jim. I
Just love to shirred you know, how good Thai food is I just very proud
They'll be fighting it out with a colossal Thai restaurant from the heart of London
Mango-tree, you are one son. Son of a I'm always fired up. I don't need Gordon sticker walking at me are some day. I'm ready
Nom Jim and the mango tree will be battling to prove they have what it takes to be my best Thai restaurant
For the first of three grueling challenges, I've dispatched 30 fervent foodies who descended each restaurant in turn and order on mass
First stop 50 miles north of Edinburgh its bonus and Andrews
This town is not only famous for his golf venue
But also Nam gym an amazing Thai restaurant is run by a dynamic duo husband and wife sandy and B
And they pride themselves on cooking authentic Thai cuisine today. I'm expecting nothing less than a hole in one
I'm gonna see anyone's cottage in the b8. No, sorry. Well husband. Sorry
The only Scot in the village
The first and only tyrant in st. Andrews nam jim's charm and authentic cuisine has taken the town by storm
It just simple, but perfect
Determine - while the locals bees even created and inspired signature dish using Scotland's national fair haggis
Face spicing it doesn't actually taste like haggis. It's a buy pork, isn't it?
That's delicious
What I love most about this place is there Jeff Abby. She's burst with energy. She's happy in her cooking
I'll stop happy and it shows in the food
Amazingly but you had never cooked professionally until she and her husband sandy openam Jim eight years ago
successful businesses all in the detail
We kind of try and be the best we can be we use the best ingredients from Thailand great service
We just won't do everything as good as a give it away. This is one the restaurants a huge following of celebrity golf fans
This is my Hall of Fame, that's a Tiger Woods's mother. Mr. Sean Connery here. Mr. Samuel Jackson
He just said thank you very much. Your food is wonderful. I was so proud
Now being Sandy's hard-fought reputation is about to be tested to his limits
My coach full of hungry diners are just around the corner. All 30 of them will expect a spotless meal in just two hours
I'm gonna be over everything not just the diamond but in the kitchen as well and as you know
I miss nothing. I'll be spotting everything
Manager sandy is in charge of keeping all my 30 diners happy penes team must explain these unique Thai dishes
One of the house specialities is the Thais Scottish haggis
We also make that with a vegetarian haggis, which is essentially pulses and nuts
Pea the orders are starting to roll now. Yeah
Yeah, as well as the haggis B's menu includes vegetarian jungle curry and tamarind up with Pak Choi
As fast as front-of-house send the orders through being her efficient type of guide on knocking out amazing food Thai cuisine
It's quick. It's not a long-winded style of cooking is done in a very fresh and sort of rapid way
Sandy the only bread on the team is the all-important link between the dining room and the kitchen
Are you at your weakest in here when they're speaking fluent?
I just kind of ignore what they're talking about like to see kind of what they're doing more than anything
So long it's a really weather of machine it's not a race to me the standards far more important, okay?
If the starters are anything to go by the standards don't seem to be a problem
Later on fire but at his hectic pace, it's vital that every member of the team is on top of every detail
This is the vegetarian wool
Sandy stop stop stop cocoa cream. There's no coconut cream on their nose mother
Before you take anything, you gotta tell her
Self-control here, isn't it? You're taking dishes. She doesn't know is John
One lamb cutlets as well guys, and that's all the start has done for everybody then
Sandy things all the starters are out but a quick scan of the dining room reveals. He's missed a whole table how
Sandy are you missing an order?
All the tables are taken here as front of house boss sandy should be all over this so that's that's all gone
No, that's all gone
Yeah
Smells nice contest
To see threes as opposed to see two
And you don't help Amazon you take food don't tell her where it's got it I'm just the fly in the ointment
Okay at last the missing table get their food
Okay, man cost me at all breathe whilst bees kitchen ramps up for the mains
Sandy's front-of-house team seemed more and more disorientated. We've got more waiters in here now than we have chefs
Do you know we're going sandy
Sandy looks a little bit. So lost there. Yeah, you know, but he comes in a little bit. Yeah, okay
So like this, we just like to like to be out right away
So you handle pressure better than he does?
Despite his confusion. Sandy's got nearly all the main courses and desserts out with 45 minutes to spare
And it's soon clear how he's done it
She's eating her - ser while I'm having my me pork
I don't think we expected that when we ordered it, you know woman you ordered. I thought you start
together
I'm sure it's best to serve the starter
Yeah cap
Main course cap and then dessert but we thought rather than somebody
Sit there eating what the partner has nothing for 20 minutes
It was less, you know for somebody to be eating at the same time
I know that's personally how I would prefer it. It does make sense
No, I agree. I'm seen it so far in the competition
Today being a kitchen team really have scored a hole-in-one. I
Went for the tie vegetarian highness which was really exquisite. The food was fantastic start to finish. It was delicious renal socks off
Worth waiting for with such fantastic food the wheat link here is clearly front-of-house. I
Spoken to the diners and not everybody enjoyed having their dessert and the main course at the same time
Dessert is a sort of sweet grand finale not to be eaten opposite a duck the saving grace today
Is that everyone loved the food?
That's for me the most important tine up get the service as good as a food in 99 percent of the way there
My best restaurant hit squad of 30 diners are on their way to the second toy restaurant battling for semi-final place in my nationwide competition
Just a stone's throw from Buckingham Palace is one of the most popular toy westerns in the capital it's mango-tree
To be here
Big destruction knock has been front of house manager of this huge 160 seat restaurant since it opened 10 years ago
I love manga 3. It's my baby. This is my life my inspiration
Even the kitchen is huge as well. How are you?
So nice to see a Englishman heading a Thai Kitchen
Way from I'm planning you have Thailand. Thank God for that
Hey check marks passion for Asian cuisine led him to work in Vietnamese and Japanese kitchens before coming to the mango tree
What we're trying to create is the essence of the Thai Street food served in an eloquent way
Is accomplished take on Thai cuisine attracts 350 diners at night on a busy weekend
By star restaurant, I really enjoy coming here is one of those places you can really trust
For mark, controlling such a vast operation is made harder by a less than ideal restaurant layout
With the kitchen and dining room on different floors, all the food is sent by left
These earpieces things like someone from the secret police
To coordinate food and service staff use radio headsets and if all else fails, there's always the phone. Yes coming right now
when a customer happy when a staff happy I
am very proud what I'm doing
With knots battalion of waiters and Mars Revere's food. This huge restaurant should find my first test at Donald
But every ration I've tested so far has struggle with my coach load of 30 dinars
Arriving in ordering all at once they'll expect every dish to be cooked to perfection
I want my diners to leave tonight, you know on cloud nine. I want their jaws on the floor really push it out
Yeah, and good luck
We got a new order to me income one chickens are tight
We're just going to do what we do best and that's the quality and the consistency of the food
You don't want to be complacent if they're thirsty pad thai there'll be 30 great pad thai
It's that simple
Mark has hand-picked a small selection of his most popular dishes for my guests tonight
including shrimp Tom Yum chicken, satay and tiger prawn pad thai
He's taking these Thai classics to a new level of sophistication
With truly authentic flavors and exquisite presentation, but upstairs front of house of discoveries made a big mistake
I
Know approach. I for this time all of the dish in here can be substitute to which carrion is not probably the soul
You don't need to worry about it
Knocks professionalism has carved a potential mutiny
Meanwhile the fish and meat eaters are loving their starters useful flavors complement each other
Amazing. I would definitely recommend
But there's a serious problem with one diners chicken, satay
The chicken Kurtis is seems quite fleshy inside and quite pink. It's absolutely yes. I
Waking up fuckers that we drank it will take another 5-10 minutes. I'm sure
You don't expect it from the top restaurant to ask my food to be sent back to the kitchen
New order one chicken satay well done
Overall your leave them
Both the chicken satay starter and the baby chicken main course a half cooked free service and finished off to order by kamyshev Nielsen on
This occasion. He's got it badly wrong heavy part cooks the chicken you want expected to go out? No
He's very annoying when we're dealing with the people that we are dealing with tonight
Mart's been quick to send up a replacement dish, but I want to see how well this lift system works
In my restaurants I can bark orders at my waiters over the pass
But here every dish that leaves the kitchen must travel up two flights of stairs by dumbwaiter - Mikey
Is his job to send the food to the right table?
What was that
Although should tell you what table is before they send the fucking thing though. Yeah
Don't know never what is coming in the legs. I can only guess seeing the foot and Perrier to the ticket
Ok, not they selling food, but no one's told me what table in terms of ticket
For this one. Yeah, so just set their diet
Please
Come on yes, there's always like this. Yeah. Fuck me. That's 430 kimochi was like was what 300?
Everything in the lift send it as service ramps up. The system is falling apart
Oh it sees the main it is yes, we wait
But most of the mistakes are picked up by the waiting staff before they hit their dining room what's wrong with that
You say nowt wrong. So I need I need this instead. Okay, send it down then. What's that? Right? It's not missing
Oh, I don't get a ticket for a Gaia but I go what table is it?
Set it down to you
This is crazy
What a mess lots of great food don't know where fast
So if you send me again table 38 they would take it they got the main cause already
That lift is busier than fucking Paris he own his knickers. Yes
Dad this list could be a nemesis you'll be given absolute total pain in the ass
He doesn't know what he's selling up there. It leaves here immaculate it goes up in the lift. They grab it out
It pisses down the side those diners are gonna get pissed off for that to me
It's nothing short of a miracle that all 30 diners eventually received the correct food
All loops lovely
Beautiful worth waiting for
I'm in heaven. I'm in heaven
But it seems once again this tables got a problem with that food
It's undercooked
After the earlier talk up with the undercooked chicken starter unbelievably it happened again, this is
To cook pasta, sorry. I said let me just take it back. I'm always afraid
To kill you just
Yeah on the bone just fuck
Diane come back walk
Mark is on the warpath
How's it possible? Huh? You know check any of them. I?
Mean look you're fucking pre-cooking them
Is it that hard?
Libby wants to eat raw chicken you
Huh
To my horror the true scale of the chicken scandal is only just unfolding
Definitely rule
Yeah, just this one that is to tell one more voice. No problems the same again
Now what?
Two more portion of chicken so they take a make sure it's well done this time. What's on that one? It's
The same time same terror yes, there it is. He's wrong I think yeah the thighs roll. Yeah
This is the last thing I expected from this incredible restaurant hf mark looks as shocked as me
This is what was talking about quality in the consistency, I'm the one who looks at Fran
Something that's almost renders it. Oh
Wait - firing. There's two two tables, but kind of messed it up
Fingers crossed for this one
This pieces of carrot, it's stunning. It's really really good. It's it's a very big difference from the last place I got
It's a credit to knock in the front of house team that the majority of Medina seemed unaffected by the Kaos
Service is amazing. So everybody good. They're really accommodating when I said I didn't like spicy food and stuff the part. I was really
Because there was a problem with the menu in the vegetarian our particular waiter has been absolutely wonderful with us really attentive
They take a great interest and to our experience here the military in the end. Most of my diner seemed happy, but
P'march has been one of the toughest nights of his career
Right west restarts. I
Know what you're capable of
You only have to read the comments - why this freshman is in this competition and the support you've got from customers is phenomenal
Then we're done is arrived. And unfortunately, they haven't had that same experience
That's where it hurts for me
Come back and come back strong
- nice
Throw all that away throw it all the way sick of looking at
Every time something isn't right. You know, I didn't take it very personally. There's no reflection that our team can't cook
Situations do happen. Sometimes it's how you rectify them is the most important thing and hopefully they
They don't happen again
Nom Jim and the mango tree have survived the coast trip now I want to meet up to review their performances
or so they think
They have no idea. I've been spying on them with the help of undercover diners who've been filming secretly
Simon Davis is a professional secret diner with an eagle eye for weak spots in restaurant food and service
Sarah Durden Roberson is a top food consultant who's been expertly dissecting menus food and service for years
I've asked them both to be demanding to see how the restaurants responding
This is just a bit too spicy for me. Could I order the chicken? I'd really like to have that
But I will get this one
First up is knob Jim
And the Mamba have to show them a front of house for Yasko that no one is prepared for
Unknown to both of you. I sent in a secret diner
That's very cool and this is what he saw good evening, I've got a table booked to name Duncan
That's the Thai haggis, thank you very much
That hang is it's a creative idea to farm that invented the spice levels perfectly pitched
It's the sort of thing that could set this restaurant a car from other Thai restaurants in the country
Actually loved it. And that kind of wow factor
my god, so chai glasses up the whites apply white a
Dear I just try a little bit I
Know I've never had Thai wine before the other one. It's gonna be like
You know, what am I gonna do with the photos
Okay, could we bring a bottle
What if it's not very nice wine, I won't want to drink it wow, that's not how we offer one service is it
something
No, that's a bit of a shock. Sorry. Yeah, okay
Okay
I
Do like that I don't think I do like that's actually yeah
I know but I told him if I didn't like it I wouldn't have it
That weight actually looked looked at me no way
Would he behave like that if you were there Sunday I
Think not what more likely to do would be probably to come and ask
What to do about the situation dad it's not ideal it is appalling I'm just shot through honesty
You know, it's wanted more I told you before over well I'm not paying for it. Oh, yeah, I basically say what anytime
Call the police
Basically, I think before if they have gone in a minute I ask for a glass of Thai wine
Okay, um
You know you gonna let me speak
and you give me the evil eye and you say to me I'm gonna you have to pay for that wine and then and then
It and then you say to me if you don't pay for that one. I'm gonna go and call the police
You call that decent service dude, I'll pay for it but I mean, that's just absurd
That ranks as about the most aggressive service I've ever seen in my life. Oh my god
I'll call the police
I'm lost for words
Incredible
What I would love to
is
I'll put out an olive branch to the manager. He takes it we kind of kiss and make up
Figuratively speaking me. Excuse me. Hi there
What's happening with the wine I
Didn't you know this visit with the police I thought it was very
You shouldn't have bread to pillow
You could see in his face he knew you shouldn't be
Sandy how does it make you feel when you see that style of service been running your business out? Yeah
I'm both shocked very embarrassed and
More than a little bit hungry, I've all that's been a very energizing experience
Many levels I'm enthusiastic and excited about the quality of the food service has been smiling
courteous off in the one blip
And I'm leaving here
Thinking I would definitely come back here and I would tell people about it and they're the two things that when you were restaurant over
You really want your diners to me
Some night
Wow you will be corrected that will never happen again
WHERE'S THE LAMB SAUCE!!
WHERE'S THE LAMB SAUCE?!?!!?
It's difficult for me to look beyond that blip
Everything you did is perfect
I'm upset, and I think it's a combination of
Being very excited and very happy and then one minute and anchoring the complete opposite end of the spectrum
You're next and you know, so I the minute I think I'm just a little bit lost for words. I'm just very
For someone to point out updates
You know because of the best service and then the thing is not it's not that not what we want
Our customers come first in everything. I
Hope we haven't blown our chances within the competition
We're gonna have to work hard
Tonight two amazing restaurants are going head-to-head in a competition to find my best restaurant in Britain
You wanna teach some young girl?
Now it's the turn of London's Thai culinary giant mango tree to get the spy treatment
How are you? Are you well?
Welcome, we've actually been tested twice
Because since I've left the mango tree I sent in my secret diners
And here's what they saw on
The coach trip head chef mark was crestfallen when undercooked chicken was sent back to the kitchen
manager NOx supervision kept them on site
But how do they do when I'm not watching
Plank on my table
They've got all these plastic wiped clean covers, but they never wipe them clean it's got food cakes all over it. It's
Nothing more disappointing first touch the menu dirty
Nutgrass noodle salad is so spicy
So anywhere I could have it but just a bit less spicy
Wow
Wow fantastic that was really close they've brought someone who saw separately in case I want to control my own measurement that's
Exactly what you should do exactly
Well handles great when somebody says they want something a certain way. We don't understand what their less spicy is. Sure
So it gives them the opportunity to to do that themselves. Oh, it was handed brilliantly
It's not very relaxing a fact that I don't know what they do. There's someone going on the back tables
Calling it's serving mats from under the cutlery. So every table he doesn't screw ching ching ching every time they do it
I feel like I've overstayed my up and they're trying to steer the tables. Would you please get out now?
I feel like saying I'm terribly sorry. Am I in your way?
What a shame when they feel that awkward and the noise is ridiculous, especially you're trying to eat dinner food
Complain about a couple of things sent them back they conveniently dealt with it
But their customer care is pretty shockingly bad
It's neither one thing nor the other they care and they don't care
Food
delicious
Second to none, but that attention detail of the service worked out for everybody
You forget that sometimes when you're doing such big numbers, so
Don't take your personally take it professionally. Absolutely
It was interesting, yeah, he's a bit of an eye-opener what we saw on the film
He's upsetting if I were customer. I I would I would say the same so I'm very
Disappointed I don't feel let down by the service because we are a team we take the Pat's on the back together
But we take the knocks together as well and we will fix it
There is more to the competition and we don't want this to be the end for us
Both restrooms have been left reeling by these revelations, but there's still everything to play for
For their final battle and bringing the chef's face to face in my flagship restaurant
I've challenged each chef to create one amazing dish for 20
Yes, but to guarantee a place in the semi-finals will have to be the finest dish of their lives
His dream, so he was very very proud
if we win, that would be
Brilliant, it was our customers that first where we are a speaks volumes that they're proud of what we're doing
Everything is focused on today and winning
Right huge pressure test this one to cook 20
stunning dishes
Make them taste absolutely delicious
Create that level of perfection sadly one of you believe in competition
And one of you we go through to the semi-final make sure it's you. Good luck
Beau freshens will be attempting to impress me with a dish made from chicken the perfect meat to complement the heady
aromatic herbs and spices used in Thai cooking
both the mango tree unarm Jim have had their ups and downs and I'm hoping that they pull that aside and
They focus on those 20 dishes and use that as they come back
Outside a dining room full of VIPs all with a passion for Thai food will help me judge both dishes tonight
Including Thai cookie writer or a cheap choice ara and one of my all-time favorite Thai chefs patria wear a pen
all the front of how teams can do is wait and hope
An order two covers away Table three the mango tree two, baby chicken chef
For mango tree head chef. Marc is sticking his neck out with a new complex
Dish made from the baby chickens that almost brought him on the coast trip
He was gutted when undercooked chicken was sent out three times
Cooked enough. I just hope he knows what he's doing today. I'm happy with that
Lovely flavor
beautiful smell
You're quite fond of baby chicken, aren't you? I am we've changed it
Obviously when we've done it in the restaurant, we've learned from our mistakes of you know, making sure it cooks
It's why I wanted to do it because I'm not gonna run away from anything good
Very balls for that baby chicken back on the menu again master suppose don't eater them him or not. So it's pure focus
Phenom Jim I'm worried that be still shaken by my secret diners bombshell
Being in here foreign kitchen, I'll know it I don't want this to affect the quality of a dish
First of all, I want to clear something really important. That's gone the wine
I want you to set that completely behind you today is about you and your food and then show me that passion. Yeah
Tonight be sticking to what she does best authentic food packed with flavor
marinated chicken with pan fried oyster mushrooms and a punchy basil puree
But to elevate this dish to my restaurants three mission star standards. She needs to be completely on the ball
Before rise please be
Serviced please. Tell us it's come on guys the food's hanging around too long
But he's making simple mistakes. All right now, please now, I'm Jim - chicken
Feet you don't even listen something after that. It's two more not four more. You've got four chicken in there
So - I'll take two chicken out
Be after this is only two more you got four in the pan so what do you take two hours
These lack of focus is beginning to worry me. I need to see her really step up to the mark. Okay
That's the last year the moment rushing let's focus on the service B. Yeah, let's focus on these yeah
B she's had a rocky ride up into this stage
I want that to be put behind her and just focus on the 20 plates and come back but come back strong
So this place level six is quick a pleasure. Thank you
I'm so nervous
About me me getting there. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. It's been a struggle, but she's got the food out
So is pleased much better yeah
Well, then be good job. Thank you Joe, please
Dish we try will be fun, aren't you? Enjoy?
The chicken it's very subtle and the sauce is beautiful it lovely aroma but presentation
I'm not quite quite confident. I thought this dish was excellent
Our please chicken disaster mark is determined every piece will be cooked to perfection today
Hon, please mark for portions table 2 in 3 minutes piece final touch is to grill it to turn the skin a delicious golden-brown
Mark your dish is it supposed to be crispy the skin when he looks any food? I don't want it to come across is burn
First table table five please Germany happy with that mark. I know
What does that fragrance again, Jasmine? Yes, very nice mark has gone the extra mile. Honey's food looks wonderful
face number five Vicki
So exciting about it from the mango tree you can see
From my face, this is Wow Excel for me. The finishing line is within sight when the unthinkable happens
I'm just a bit disappointed cuz actually as you can see this has not really cooked
Let me show it to the chef. Okay, I mean it'll be taken away for you
Took
Double six feet service. I need you to not have any with this chef. They said their chicken is under cuts
Where's the under our fucking line?
There's their last I can come off the bone there. You see it clear as day. Fuck me
Fuck
Damn I was so pissed off
Pink chicken comes back again. And if there was ever time not to serve it is right now not good enough for more mark
Please how long just give me terms. I can tell the time. You'll agree minute three minutes of Table one, please
Tell Rob don't worry rather leg. Yeah, fuck the leg
Pretty pissed off
They treat my own words. I'm not happy
Marc you checked all them see them underneath as well. Yeah. Yeah, go. Tell one pleasure
And I could never have guessed servers would end like this for mango tree
It's been a challenging night for everyone
But it's time to find out what my diner's thought on both dishes starting with mango tree
Let's talk chicken while ours wasn't cooked. No. Well, that was a ridiculous mistake. My apologies
It just wasn't even leaving the Bommel day. It was probably still clucking
Fortunately not all my diners had the same experience it's so great when it came
Yes, and when we tasted it their hopes go right through it
I
Preferred the mango tree because I loved the chicken on the bone
it kept it really moist very very tasty and the broth with it just
Worked lovely all I had to go for 19 because I like this song so much is beautifully marinated subtle
And then you've got the sauces complement
Creation phenom Jim. Yes, and she carries it lovely but the rice is bit too much water. I mean, you know your rice
Now I face a very difficult choice which one of these two restaurants should go through to the semi-finals
For Gordon Ramsay to say you the best that is meant a lot I
Will never forget it neither restaurant has been without fault, but even good restaurants have their bad days
I'm obviously hoping at the other 19 dishes
Make a bigger impact and impression than the one but can I forgive mark for under cooking chicken again?
By two top tie contenders, nom Jim and mango tree have completed a lower biting service in my flagship restaurant
Both chefs to produce an incredible dish but both have fallen short of perfection
Now I have to choose which restaurant is truly deserving of a place in the semi-final
But first I need to make my own judgment on both dishes
Now Jim it looks slightly clumsy
Chickens delicious
It's got that nice crispy texture of the outside you spare that sauce on top of that chicken
The whole thing just comes alive not eye catching but math walking and taste
Mango-tree have gone the extra mile and it looks like he's been done with great finesse flair lovely
The broth is almost like a sort of Tom Yum Goong there's like two dishes in one
Rice soft fluffy and concurrently fragrant nice little spray on the end with that. Jasmine really nice chickens delicious
I'm just slightly nervous about that soft chewy skin should be crispy
- remarkable Thai restaurants, but only one can continue through to the next round
Okay
Right, I
Brought both Russians here to give you an opportunity a unique opportunity to really cook like you've never cooked before
Now I'm Jim. I saw the dish. It didn't look the most appetizing
Having been to your restaurant and seen the style
In which you deliver food? It was a little bit of a surprise to see something. So basic as that, I
Tasted the chicken and bang. It was just yeah, it was amazing
however at this station the competition
This round is not won on a single dish
Now Jim secret diners, no experienced food like that. Absolutely loved that food haggis in a Thai restaurant
Doesn't even sound right?
But for you to turn into something that goes very few Russians can do that anywhere
My good streak
The fascinating thing with you Mars. You're not even you know in from Thailand you seem to have this magic with Thai cuisine
that is a
Is a gift and with mango trees at its best is untouchable. It's ending our secret diner
Absolutely blown away with that food. I mean really really
Blown away with that food to do the boots that began at this stage of the competition. I admire the balls
It was sweet, it was delicious and
Authentic. How could I criticize that how could I look at that dish and tell you how to do it better? I
Didn't have to the first time this competition. I just came back
You've left with a very tough decision
The restaurant going through to the semi-final is
Nom Jim congratulations
Well done yes, whoo - Tommy
Why don't you with your touch and the man experience you have with Thai cuisine? I know you've got more coming
Very disappointed, you know, I'm cycling hard and north and the team and our customers down, but you know
That's the way it goes, you know, which man came all the luck
Pissed off at the moment
Someone never told me before I'm good and I'm into this competition so
It means so much for me. It's a bit mind-boggling first. We were all very very proud and a little bit shops and stunned
I think
What an amazing day and two great restaurants
I'll be sorry to say goodbye to mango tree but the same hand we've opened the door to something quite magical
Vincent Andrews because they are a force to be reckoned with
But for Nam gym now the competition really starts because the next stage of this competition. It's gonna be even tougher